Jesse in Montana you're on the bench
Bureau struggle for Jesse hello thanks
taking a call sure my Balu for about
four years now you were about a couple
of years ago you were actually my
gateway to kind of getting into
philosophy a little bit all right and
listening to a lot I've been really
enjoying of your show I actually think
is that it's best when you kind of let
judeo-christian for principles and
philosophy kind of bleed in to the
substance but anyway I'm a
non-denominational libertarian Christian
mm-hmm I'm I'm kind of in this like a
bit of a circular logic that I can't
really get out of maybe you could
enlighten me a little bit I'm in this
place where I think that you actually
can't find any real objective morality
without God or a creator okay but I'm
also in this place where like what if
there's like it what if there's a
hypothetical where a god or a creator
asks you or instructs you to do
something more right so you yeah I mean
we could take something really basic
like what if what if God tells you to
kill a baby or something like that right
exactly
morality is only objective if God says
so what if she would then tell you to do
something immoral like by our by our
standards right so this is this has been
called for a long time the uthra pro
dilemma youth approach dilemma from
Plato's Republic
the basic idea being that what if if God
is the source of all morality and God
tells you to do something wrong then he
isn't the actual source of all morality
so the the in the Bible this is mostly
dealt with in sort of judeo-christian
heritage this is mostly dealt with in
the story of Abraham and Isaac right
which is a horrifying story on its
surface and this is why Richard Dawkins
the famed atheist picks it sort of out
of the biblical pile and says well this
is a perfect example of what biblical
morality looks like God telling father
to kill his son to murder his son and
this is treated as a great sign of faith
by people of faith to me that is a
dramatic miss read of what the Abraham
and Isaac story is about basically what
that story is about and you can find
this in the text pretty easily is
Abraham acknowledging that God's
Authority is sacrosanct but also
trusting that God is not going to force
him to do something immoral because on
the surface of it God's request to
Abraham is so bizarre
first of all Abraham in sort of Jewish
theology had always been rebelling
against the greatest of all
which was the sacrifice of children to
pagan gods I mean the Bible itself bans
the the killing of children for the god
Molech where I mean it literally says
this in the Bible so the idea that God
would then tell Abraham to kill his own
child his bizarre to Abram but Abram
doesn't argue Abraham argues with God on
a number of occasions most specifically
he argues with God about the destruction
of Sodom and Gomorrah he says well if
you can find this many righteous people
and this many righteous people
you shouldn't go forward with it and God
accepts the logic and then when no
righteous people are there to be found
then he destroys the city but the the
but in this circumstance Abraham doesn't
actually argue with God about what would
seem to be the most immoral thing right
God telling him to kill his only Son the
only way to explain that from a
judeo-christian perspective is to say
that Abraham had enough trust in God to
understand that God was testing
Abraham's willingness to obey Authority
and Abraham's faith that God would be
doing the right thing that God would not
force him to go through with the actual
murder of his own son now where that
comes down in terms of judeo-christian
faith is from a from a sort of realistic
perspective there many times in life in
which circumstance forces horrible
things upon us and we sort of just have
to accept them as an element of the
universe as an element of God's justice
that we don't understand
but we have faith that God is acting
morally even when he appears to be
acting immorally and in this case when
the when the choice is made explicit by
God Himself God is the one who changes
his mind or maybe didn't change the mind
in the first place maybe he never meant
to go through with it in the first place
so the the problem of his man's morality
sacrosanct or is God's morality sank
respect the point that I've always made
about your day of Christian morality is
that judeo-christian morality rests on
certain fundamental premises that you
simply have to assume in order to even
discern a moral system so both natural
law systems of thought and Talmudic
systems have thought assume that you can
actually learn basic things about
morality from the world around us based
on certain premises that you have to
accept those premises cannot be found in
science the sacrosanct nature of human
life is a perfectly obvious one the
inestimable value of every human life so
the most important sentence in human
history in my view is the sentence from
Genesis in which God says that man was
made in his image this was a change from
prior systems of thought and you can
read ancient pagan religion in which
they talked about the king being made in
God's image
but human beings generally were not seen
to be made
that created a sort of species equality
number one the human beings are all
equal to each other in terms of the
rights that they have from God and in
terms of the court and and in terms of
the value that they have before God and
also in terms of the the inability to
violate somebody else's right to life
for example that's not something that
you can find an evolutionary biology
this is always the question that I've
asked Sam Harris and other atheists who
believe that you can discern a certain
level of morality simply from the world
around them what an evolutionary biology
suggests that an individual human life
is worth anything nothing in
evolutionary biology suggests anything
remotely like that you have to take as
given that individual human lives are
worth something in order to build a
moral system from that and that has to
be based it has to be predicated on the
innate stature of an individual human
life and religion makes this clear by
saying well God made human beings in His
image and therefore they have
inestimable value you can then discern a
system of morality from that now when is
that when that comes in conflicts with
what you believe to be values given by
God then you have to determine are you
really properly interpreting the values
that have been given by God or are you
or are you possibly attempting to
override God's values with your own and
this is why sometimes people will look
I'm an Orthodox Jew right so I keep this
stuff pretty pretty strictly people will
look at the Bible and they'll pick and
they'll pick things out and they'll say
well what about this seemingly
ridiculous position and what I've always
said and the tongue the talmud makes
this clear to even in in Judaic thought
is that there are certain sort of
eternal principles about human nature
that are embedded in the Bible and those
are the things that are discernible from
the text of the Bible and then there are
things that are sort of time bound
Commandments and commandments of the
time and an exigencies of the time and
we have to determine that so I've never
believed in the in the fulsome sort of
non logic based approach to religion
neither did my mana teas and Judaism or
Thomas Aquinas and Christianity the you
have to God gave a documents if you're a
Bible believer God gave a document of
morality to human beings knowing that
human beings were then going to apply
their own logic to that document God
knew that and he expected that and in
fact he wanted that to happen because
otherwise he theoretically could have
frozen humanity in place at the time so
morality is not above God but we do
trust in God to abide by a morality that
he's that he gave us in the first place
right God gave us our moral sense I mean
even Immanuel Kant who who was not
exactly a purely religious philosopher
suggested that he found evidence of God
in man's innate sort of moral
sensibility which was embedded and then
we were given certain basic premises
that are not discernible from from the
pure materialistic world around us Jesse
thank you appreciate it that basically
answered my questions I appreciate it
things I always I always like asking
questions I'm glad that you asked one I
love your Torah reads on Friday night on
the end of your Friday show by the way
that's very sweet of you thank you well
we'll try and get back to that on
tomorrow's show really appreciate the
call Kurt in Burnsville Minnesota I'm
Ben Shapiro show go for it Kurt just a
big failure show on all your Facebook
and all the good stuff um and I was
reading problems as watching something
called disco talks about how the
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
says he is a Democratic Socialist um
I think that's kind of funny become kind
of third piece there's no difference
between a regular socialist and identify
a socialist right well the problem is
they refused to find the term so they'll
say Democratic Socialist and what you're
supposed to read from that is that we
were talking about Norway or Denmark and
we are not talking about Cuba or
Venezuela or the Soviet Union but of
course the People's Republic of North
Korea says it is a People's Republic
right just cause you call yourself a
Democratic Socialist does not mean that
you are necessarily democratic what do
you mean by by Democratic the modifier
Democratic only means that you like
voting sometimes but not every time and
also Democratic used to mean sort of in
in common parlance Democratic used to
mean one of two things either your pure
majoritarian meaning you think we should
vote on everything which is an immoral
system right it is an immoral system if
you believe that all rights are subject
to the basic whim of a majority you can
very easily end up with the slaughter of
minority by a majority you can easily
end up with Jim Crow you can end up with
slavery
obviously democracy in and of itself is
not inherently moral the question of
democracy the reason that democracy is
moral if it is moral is because it
recognizes the individual right so
democracy without individual rights is
inherently undemocratic in certain basic
ways so that that's why the phrase
democratic socialists is always sort of
as misnomer if Democrats were honest
about this or Bernie were honest who
just comes with Social Democrat right a
social democrat is is a person who
believes in free markets and then
believes
heavy social strictures on top of that
social welfare programs that that would
be Norway or Denmark and Social
Democrats in these countries call
themself Social Democrats they don't
call himself Democratic Socialist there
is a difference between the two terms
calling themselves Democratic Socialist
means that you reject the profit motive
means you reject the free market and
Bernie wants to kind of grab the mantle
of radical while at the same time just
sort of distancing himself from the
mantle of radical by suggesting that
what he really only means is a bigger
government superstructure which by the
way is no difference from FDR LBJ so
this is always been the weird thing
about Bernie is what exactly is he and
he refuses to say exactly what a back in
the 70s he said clearly what he was it
was a communist right he was a full-on
socialist state run business communists
now he sort of wants to be halfway he
doesn't really wanted to find it but
when someone says Democratic Socialist
you need to ask them do are you talking
about government ownership of the means
of production
end of story that is the question right
because socialism is that and then if
you mean that you're gonna do that via
democracy then you're still talking
about the violation of individual rights
the vagary and the terms is how
socialists get away with with couching
the more radical than more radical
viewpoints in the rhetoric of consent of
the people when again you cannot consent
to the violation of your own individual
rights Kurt so do you think that that
Bernie's is he trying to try to get more
votes by saying he oh no I'm not a
falselist I'm a Democratic Socialist you
think he's just trying to get more of
Old Spice by by trying to change the
word so I was people with more more
people vote for him yes so what he's
doing is he's saying to his base I am a
socialist and then he is saying to
everybody else I'm a Democratic
Socialist so I'm not really scary and
the reason that he insists on calling
himself a socialist is because he wants
a labeled distinction between himself
and Elizabeth Warren or between himself
and people to judge because the fact is
that if you look at their actual
policies Elizabeth Warren's policy she
calls herself a non socialist right
Elizabeth Warren's policies are
indistinguishable from Bernie's they're
very very close on every level and the
same thing is basically true of Peabody
judge with very minor distinctions so a
Bernie does is he wants the branding
separation of socialism without having
to live with the reality which is that
socialism is a cruel unjust and evil
system that has failed everywhere it has
actually been tried in terms of
government ownership of the means of
production Curt really appreciate the
call Andre in San Antonio Texas here on
the bench Peter sure go for it Andre
thank you for taking my call Ben sure go
for so my question is the federal brand
the federal executive branch has over 3
million employees 1.2 of which are non
military do you think it would be a good
idea to split the executive branch into
more than one elect at an individual for
example the Texas executive branch has
nine elected position and it would clear
and to be clear I am asking because I
think the unelected officials and the
cabinet positions are getting comparable
not because I think the president's
position itself is too powerful so the
the this was considered by the founders
right so the founders actually talked
about in the Federalist Papers the idea
of either a rotating executive or a
shared power of executive and the reason
they came up with a singular executive
is because they wanted the executive to
be able to act with alacrity and act
quickly the idea of having elected
officials in in the executive branch
more more than one I could see the case
for it I suppose if you want a diffusion
of authority so long as those people are
able to be recalled if they're elected
individually if it creates more gridlock
frankly at this point I'm in favor of it
so more gridlock in the executive branch
sounds it sounds great to me in the idea
of an executive branch where the AG is
at odds with the president who is also
at odds of the Secretary of State like
I'm not sure that that's a terrible
thing I think on a federal level when it
comes to foreign policy that's a problem
I think on a state level it's it's less
of a problem you also presumably don't
want the AG constantly going after the
the governor of a state for example
having them be different members of the
of different parties and have them
completely at odds
I see the upsides I see the downsides
but I could see the argument for I'd be
willing to hear the argument for Dondre
I really appreciate the call Daniel in
New Jersey are on the bench Bureau shall
go forward Daniel yeah how are you today
mr. spiro election is actually a little
straight out of the headline sure today
the House voted to remove a previously
existing and extended ratification
deadlines for the ER a the Equal Rights
Amendment Congress can extend deadlines
that haven't yet passed but do you think
they should be able to remove ones that
expire now of course in addition to that
Ginsburg yeah go ahead Daniel but but I
mean the reality is and of course this
is insane this is completely
sane okay if a law expires and then
you're like oh well we just revived it
magically without like a full vote of
the Senate in the way that you normally
do a constitutional amendment so it's
back on the table and all of the states
that voted for this thing back in 1978
it's like they voted for it today like
our politics is different in 1978 than
they are today
a little okay so if they had when they
passed the Equal Rights Amendment there
was a natural expiration date on the
Equal Rights Amendment it expired you
don't just get to undo the past by going
whoops we unexpired it and it turns out
that all the states who voted that year
based on the expiration of the e ra will
just count them we'll just count them
that's not the way any of this crap
works right notorious RBG who is
worshipped by the left they turned on
her this week because she pointed out
what is perfectly obvious apparently
well RBG is very bad at reading the
constitution she's still capable of
reading basic English because obviously
this is not constitutional obviously you
cannot just undo a dead letter
it's just ridiculous Daniel it's
ridiculous on its face yeah that was
actually exactly what the second part of
my question was gonna get into but in
furtherance of that do you think that
she would actually pose a fifth vote
assuming the four Republican nominated
justices voted together to uphold what
the OLC said that the deadline passed
they this thing's dead no interests at
all like if I trusted RBG to be honest
then I'd have a lot more faith in our
Supreme Court I have a feeling that RBG
would then go well you know well I think
that this is really this is really bad
you know well well I think she said I
would like to see a new beginning I'd
like to see it start over there's too
much controversy about late comers
Virginia long after the deadline passed
but she might say well you know but in
reality the controversies actually over
evolving standards of decency and all
that I'd go far like I just don't trust
RBG but she obviously is speaking the
truth when she says that the deadline is
over it's ridiculous I mean this is just
ridiculous garbage Daniel she was
absolutely decent enough to recognize
that not only were there late comers
supporting it but those who supported it
before the 78 or 82 dead lawyers sorry
79 or 80 to deadlines actually have
rescinded their ratification right well
that is true as well
proponents will say that they can't do
that Ginsburg said well if we're gonna
count the ones who come in we have to
count the ones who want out
so I don't know where the Matthews yeah
I hope you know
I'm less sanguine about people's honesty
then and then I was when I was younger
and I get I get more and more cynical as
the days go by but at the same time I
mean what she said on this is absolutely
true Daniel really appreciate the call
zenki in Algeria you're on the bench
Shapiro sure go for it zenki hello Ben
first of all I would like to say that
I'm not a huge fan of your show for
quite a while now
and this is coming from someone living
in a totally far country my question is
about socialism right I just don't
understand why in a country such as
America people still advocate an idea
like socialism and another person that's
experiece and it's bad consequences like
firsthand I don't I don't understand how
come like intellect to lecture people
and politicians still advocate such an
idea despite the overwhelming evidence
that this is not correct and it's a bad
idea
yeah I mean it's I think that it comes
down to a couple things first of all
socialism like true socialism is is very
popular in areas where it has not
actually been effectuated you know
people from socialist countries
understand that you have to flee
socialism to three countries people in
free countries were like wouldn't it be
nice if there were a brotherhood of man
and and things were different than they
are
socialism is just basically a buzzword
for utopian scheming and that's very
easy to do in a country where things are
fairly prosperous and free I think
beyond that socialists in the in the
West have done an excellent job of
obscuring their actual positions so what
they will do is they'll say well I'm not
a socialist I'm a Democratic Socialist
I'm not a socialist I'm a syndicalism
I'm not a socialist I'm a person who
believes in free hope cut for everybody
and it's like well no you need to
explain what you mean do you mean
government ownership of the means of
production that is the definition of
socialism if you're suggesting that
socialism trust means being fair or nice
to each other no I'm also for being fair
and nice to each other if you mean that
the government gets to cram down on
everybody else how businesses are run
that the government gets to decide on
the redistribution of all resources for
purposes of fairness then we got a
problem on our hands and if people were
honest we could discuss gradations of
this stuff because there are gradations
right I mean the fact is that you can
have a social system in a capitalist in
a capitalist economy the National Health
Service in Britain is a great example of
a socialist system in a capitalist
economy and you can talk about whether
that's effective whether that's
ineffective whether they're better
systems are worse but
instead when people say socialist what
they really mean it's just a buzzword
for utopia and buzzwords for utopia
never match the reality of utopian
attempts that they generally fall flat
yeah I get that but you know many times
like I try to speak with people that
advocate such ideas and we get shut down
like we are a species posted on them and
there is advocating for it like we try
to ask some question what we are doing
wrong here
like what you're saying is not the same
as what we are living what we are doing
wrong that is affecting our life so bad
yeah if you have cancer here you can get
free treatment but it's mediocre
treatment they don't even let it talk
you know that's right one of the keys
about socialism is that you make sure
that nobody can actually it's like Fight
Club the first rule of socialism is that
when you're in the socialist Club you're
not allowed to talk about social it's
like what you're saying in communist
China right now right the first rule of
Communist China has never talked about
how bad Communist China is so does that
keep really appreciated : thanks for
listening from abroad really appreciate
it let's see one more question
see Jake in Poway California here on the
bench beer sure go for Jake hey then hi
how are you hey doing well go for it sir
right on my question is regarding the
polarization between the two parties
since there's such a great divide
between these two great political
entities you know in a sense where the
left is drifted so far away from
themselves I mean I understand the
Milton Friedman version of what a true
liberal is right the fact that they just
is so far away from the political party
is doing fringe on the Constitution yeah
Jake I mean I think that the bottom line
is that when it comes to polarization
we're gonna need to rediscover the roots
of the country and we're gonna need to
address what we have in common right now
the answer is not very much so unless we
find something in common whether it is
belief in founding principles whether it
is even a common cultural sort of sphere
that we occupy we're going to need
something otherwise this is just going
to keep coming up our